tell us about sudo calibrations is a new
technique in thank you very much for
inviting me it's a pleasure to be back
here is it today we'll talk about Co
calibration a technique that was
developed for the recent almost height
lower sum of squares lower bound for
very planted cleek and in fact much of
this work was done in in these very
halls so what is see their calibration
and when can be applied well let me
start with the second question first so
we can apply it on planted problems
where
we're planning problems
I thought problems asked can't we
distinguish given a single sample can we
distinguish
with high probability
between a random distribution and a plan
and a planted distribution I guess
that's us it depends help one more
phrase computationally efficiently and
yeah it depends on the problem and in
particular for most this hawk will focus
on
low degrees almost grass
okay so not funny let me get let me give
some examples for planted problems
so
so so one example is the plant cleat
problem which we worked on extensively
so here for our random distribution we
take G n 1/2 which is a random graph
where each edge is there or not there
with probability 1/2 and then for for
our planned distribution so most of it
is still random but we also have I also
have a planted queek what this means is
so
so I'll take each vertical will put each
vertex vertex in the cleek
with probability K over N where K is a
parameter which is the expected size of
the clique
and then like all the berries which you
chosen to put it put in put in the plan
cleek will make them all adjacent to
each other so it's to supplant a click
there
[Music]
so it's mostly random but there's a
planted click and a second example
is random 3x or
so in the random distribution
we'll have n em random parity equations
say like X X 1 plus X 2 plus X 7 equals
0 mod 2 X 2 plus X 4 plus X 5 equals 1
mod 2
and then in the planned distribution
you're right way bigger pull out with
this board for holes from this side and
erase some stuff yeah yeah yeah I guess
all yeah always
yeah that one hasn't hit stuff yeah this
for now I had and then for the for the
planet distribution so we'll start with
so I'll start with is as a random
solution
at X naught right
and I want to do the end and then we'll
choose
[Music]
choose M constraints hurt em parity
equations
at random
I can grab it under the condition that
they agree with with our chosen solution
X naught
[Music]
oh it's true three variables and then
you see if they add up to zero to one
yeah exactly so like you know you choose
three variables see under X naught do
they add are they zero or one not two
and then like you have that Battier of
cure equation okay and now as I said so
now what does what what - through the
calibration do you see two calibration
is a technique for showing
so these distributions are hard to
distinguish and this gives us
it's so this give us into integrality
gaps for so much of the talk will focus
on some squares
but a good chance that the techniques
here is too low probably there's a good
chance admit that the technique can be
applied for other other linear programs
and seven happenin programs
okay so now what kind of
yeah what kind of results hey can we
show with to their calibration so yeah
so you say here else I'll start with a
recent almost height lower bound for a
planet Creek it says that the need to
golly gap on random graphs is a almost
the square root of n so let me make a
few remarks on this D divided by log n
where D is is the degree of the sum of
squares so the general general idea is
that as d gets higher the like the the
sum of squares hierarchy performs better
and this says this this is this is the
trade off which which we prove although
I get I'm finding the exact trade off is
I guess tell hope this it was a constant
times the square root of D over log n so
in particular at D equals log n then
like there's no longer a lower bound
which which is good because has I'll
describe now at D equals log N and how
to times log n the problem the problem
is easily solved
that's gonna say here both D equals zero
of log in and the square root of n are
tight so the reasons for this so if you
look at random graph with and with high
probability the largest clique
in a random graph
as sighs almost exactly to login
so if if D is much bigger than to log in
degree D SOS can certify
yeah I should say for the ease that
there's there's there's an input graph G
consider by the input graph G has no
larger quick
and this is essentially by brute force
search
and a second even degree to SOS
and certify G has no cleek all these are
probabilistic statements that has no
cleek of size more than wasn't about
square root of n
and this is and this is by looking at
I can values of the adjacency matrix
and this is essentially the algorithm
algorithm had a KS 98 so in the plan to
click out the parameter K which
determine how large your clique would be
yep to be larger than log n oh yeah a
good question yes the the here will say
that K is K is much bigger than 2 log n
because because it was smaller you
couldn't information theoretically you
couldn't distinguish it from from from
what's already there
and as I'm discussing now we'll want K
to be a much less than square root of n
because at square root of n I got
spectral algorithm can certify this
there's no such click and what we're
showing is like up to almost square root
of n as as almost like sum of squares at
that fails to certify this and and and
has like a large so it has this
integrality gap almost a square root of
n so if there's a clique of size large
as and ruto event and the degree to it
SOS can certify it and it can be in
private yes and this is essentially the
spectral algorithm the AKS 98
are there further questions but before
before I'd continue
right I and unless the last remark I'll
make about this is that it's not easy
it's not easy to prove the lower bound
in particular before before cedar
calibration
at previous previous approaches
[Music]
so we were stuck at at about end to the
Omega 1 over D o n to the O 1 over D
okay and and now for preparedness for
random to X or a classic result a big
where you have says that as long as the
number of clauses isn't too large the
then even very high degree sum of
squares thinks things that they're all
solvable and this but this result you
don't need pseudo calibration that said
there'd be in recent work inspired by
suited calibration
so km sorry Maury O'Donnell and Whitmer
they proved tight SOS lower bounds we're
all
well average-case CES peace
yeah so these these are the kind of
results that we can I can share with
pseudo calibration so now let me
describe degree D sum of squares
they're actually but before I do that oh
yeah yes now let me describe degree D as
a sum of squares here we won't describe
it in general but we'll describe it or
max cleek
and give and give the general ideas for
how you would apply it more generally
okay so Supermax leaked let's let's
let's actually start with we have we
have we have an input graph G
let's start with the the basic SDP which
responds a degree to SRS so in the
intended solution
well we want X I equals 1 if I is in the
clique and 0 otherwise
and then and we'll also want that mij
equals x I times XJ now of course we'll
have to relax this so what so what kind
of things can take can we say so so X I
squared is going to be 0 or 1 but all we
could really say there is that well I am
I I is at most 1 well we want this to be
a clique so we better have that m IJ is
0
whenever I is not adjacent to J
and and third so here like Emma in the
tenth solution M the rank one PSD matrix
so I'll get really like constraint or
sorry I probably am is to say that M
should be PSD and the and the objective
value the objective function we're
trying to maximize sum over I of M I
this list so this would be a pay basic
SDP for Mac for maximum clique
so now degree the sum of squares so here
we'll this nine sublevel have a lot a
large image large matrix and now it'll
be indexed by by subsets st of size at
most D over - yeah so here so here I
should give a definition so till define
XV to be the product of I and V of X I
so now it's a similarly similarly to
before throw in our intended solution
so our X ID equals one if I maybe before
we want X I equals 1 if I is in the
clique 0 otherwise
in particular X s is equal to 1 f F is a
subset of the clique in zero otherwise
and oh an MST will want to be the
product of X XS x xt
and now for a relaxation so here so I'll
need a normalization condition
we better have that M s T is zero if s
Union T is not a quick
Oh
we'll have a bunch of symmetry
constraints so M s prime T prime should
equal an MST if these correspond to the
same name subset that's prime Union T
prime equals s Union T again we'll have
a mov PSD and and again but again we'll
have exactly the same the same objective
function we're trying to maximize sum
over I of M I I using the first one why
the identity matrix is not a feasible
solution this program that you wrote
down
let's see
we actually went as
I yeah I think yeah I think you're right
that actually thank you I think that
there was about that that I do need and
you need a row for the empty sets that I
think oh yeah okay again I need em empty
set empty set
one M empty set I equals M III so maybe
you you said it implicitly or so you
input graph this G and on your on your
second-degree DSOs I see how you matrix
and your condition depends on G because
you say has unity it better be a clique
yes it's it's right it's right here like
if f it in G this is like that if I if I
is not so here's here the same thing
just with I did this with a single I I
and J this I always sorted X I XJ but
you meant another Jason to Jake okay
okay yes oh yeah Lucy this here when
that was not adjacent okay I actually
write actually this actually yeah good
point
let me let me think about this this
question and prepare and wraps get get
back to you at the end
because right now let me
I have but now let me talk about pseudo
calibration
[Music]
so so what's your calibration does is it
gives it's a technique for finding a
feasible solution M that's to the degree
the degree dsos a semi definite program
which I described here actually that the
put that actually be me
so I said it gives them some general
general ideas for how you write the
degree sum of squares in general so
generally you'll have a large large
matrix M indexed by monomials
degree at most D over to your hat you'll
have many constraints which you can do
you can derive from the intended
solution
and
and you'll have a lot a lot of symmetry
can say constraint saying that entries
corresponding to the same manolio
have the same value
yes this is a flavor for how you would
how you get the degree D sum of squares
program more generally okay but now net
now let me return to pseudo calibration
so see the calibration is a technique
for finding a feasible solution to this
degree D sum of squares SDP okay so this
missile seems somewhere out of the blue
but let me will give an emotive ation
for it soon so so here we'll start with
the following the following function
approach for taking a graph input graph
or an input I and obtaining a I'm a a
matrix they'll define lambda st of an
input i should be the relative ten
density of I which is equal to the
probability in a planted distribution in
the flattest region of obtaining I
divided by the probability in the random
distribution of obtaining I
they're here so you should know this
earlier but the plant distribution is
actually a joint distribution on an
input I add and a solution X
so
we'll have here's I'll have and then
while the expected value given that the
input was I of XS x xt
okay so I guess I'll so I'll first start
with some observations about this about
this function
so there are the key observation is that
it satisfies satisfies everything except
a normalization
so so why so why is this true here so
the reason is that so it it's either
zero if if the input is not in is not in
the plant distribution
[Music]
or it's a constant time a large constant
very large constant times
[Music]
a distribution over over actual
solutions the actual intended solutions
Edie okay
a key idea is that by design
and intended solutions
and I satisfy they could satisfy the
constraints
so it's automatically point-wise
satisfies all the constraints accepts
normalization however the problem is
that this function here fails
normalization badly particular this
relative density mu I it's it's almost
our zero and then on on graphs which are
part of the plant distribution it's it's
exponentially large so it's it's badly
behaved so what what can we do so so the
plan - the plan distribution is a
distribution on on inputs so it says
like yeah and on grass or more generally
on inputs and so what it's saying so it
gives it so each input has some
probability yeah and and the idea is the
so the main distribution takes every
input ie with equal probability the
plant distribution like I'll have it's
much much higher weight on on the inputs
which which or just actually have a
solution X conditioned on is so assuming
that you are planted then X is the key
so yeah I act as actually it's a joint
test the flenders machine is a joint
distribution on inputs and solutions so
I guess it's it's possible though it
turns out like not pretty rare that
there could be multiple axes but this is
just saying it given given that the
input is I take the expected value over
the corresponding X's of XS times X T is
just the moments of the actual yes and
what is everything
everything would here it would be these
these three conditions here okay
okay
so I'll say the key idea and then hand
things over to my co-speaker Sam so
okay so let's a lambda here is is badly
behaved how am i we fixed that so the
key idea is we'll we'll only take the
low degree part of lambda and and and
we'll hope this smooth oh this smooth
thing this smooth lend out
and Samuel will well make this more
precise in the seconds I can happen to
talk for now for now are there are there
any questions before so you said there's
an anti-guerrilla to get for security
SOS are you talking about the specific
degree DSS that you gave us you or would
that also apply to if I add some more
conditions I'm applying to the specific
degree D SOS which which I gave here
all right thanks Aaron bye on I have my
own a justice that has to unmute me okay
thanks a lot
okay so Thank You Aaron um I want to I
want since we've gotten we've gotten our
key definition up and I'm gonna spend
most of the last 20 minutes discussing
it but before I do I want to spend a
couple of minutes on just the global
picture here because we've gotten a sort
of detail so just to refresh ourselves
the project was to is to understand
integrality gaps for very strong semi
definite programming relaxations we
thought about SDP is from the sum of
squares hierarchy but you could imagine
these ideas also working for strong
linear programs or even other kinds of
SDPs
and the main difficulty in producing
integrality gaps for the semi-definite
programs is that one has to construct
these moment matrices these are large
positive semi-definite matrices that
obey obey very complicated linear
constraints so this is you know we've
seen some explicit families have rather
complicated linear constraints as we've
noted you could even imagine adding more
of them and in the in the before pseudo
calibration era like the project of
constructing such a moment matrix was
some you know very difficult creative
task it was not at all clear how you
should choose the entries of this matrix
if you want to construct a moment matrix
that's supposed to if you want a generic
construction that was supposed to sort
of work for a random graph it was really
not clear how you should set have the
entries of this moment matrix depend on
a random input and the point of pseudo
calibration is that it gives you totally
mechanically a candidate moment matrix
to analyze to prove an integral 'ti gap
like either of these or for a variety of
other problems because you specify a
family of random instances that you want
to prove an integral T gap for you
specify some planted distribution of
instances instances that have a large
integral solution with a large objective
value so here the integral the the
planted distribution we've been talking
about as this planted clique thing the
graphs in this planted clique
distribution they have a large clique a
large integral solution and sudo
calibrations to take these things and
mechanically tells you a candidate
moment matrix construction to prove an
integral T gap analyzing that Canada
moment matrix might be very difficult
right now we have a few techniques for
it it's not clear we have the simplest
or the correct proofs for these yet
although we we can in specific cases you
know prove prove results like this but
the point is that this construction
would have required a great deal of
creativity and it now becomes mechanical
ok so if there are not if there are
questions about the global picture I'd
be happy to discuss it otherwise I'm
going to return to specifics about how
you do this mechanical construction of a
candidate moment matrix ok cool so
so Aaron set us up with this function
lambda lambda let's just sanity check
here lambda sort of has the right um the
right types you know it takes takes an
instance of your problem and for the
remainder of the talk I'm just gonna
think about planted click and it should
be understood that these ideas are quite
generic they can apply to CS peas they
can apply to a number of sort of machine
learning problems lambda it takes an
input to your problem in our case a
graph and it produces an end to the D by
n to the D matrix so lives in the space
of moment matrices and it point-wise
satisfies many of the constraints of the
sum of squares SDP so this is great it's
it's always a PSD matrix it point-wise
satisfies most of the most of linear
constraints but the main problem is that
this function is ridiculously spiky
right
for most graphs it's 0 and for a very
small fraction of graphs exponentially
few it's got a huge value right because
it's just focused on graphs that
actually have large integral solutions
and now the idea is that
our our candidate moment matrix will be
the projection of this function lambda
to low degree polynomials in the graph G
okay so I'm gonna make this precise in a
second what is a low degree polynomial
in a graph well you know think of a
graph as being an N by n adjacency
matrix of zeros and ones and then you
could imagine evaluating a low degree
polynomial in those variables but in
lambda itself is an extremely high
degree polynomial but it has a low
degree part and that's what we're going
to use as our as our candidate moment
matrix so I'm gonna do some fairly brief
discussion of this so the sudo
calibrated moment matrix
comes with some parameter capital D D is
the degree of polynomials that will
project this function lambda to so it's
gonna be
it gives tells me a value for every one
of the variables in my sum of squares
sdp in fact it tells me how that should
depend on a graph G so here we were
talking about generic instances but I'm
just gonna focus on planted cleek so G's
are graphs um and it says that what you
should do is just evaluate the low
degree projection of lambda OMG and to
define this I'm gonna give you some very
brief refresher on discrete Fourier
analysis and then we're gonna derive a
very explicit expression for this moment
matrix M for the entries of this moment
matrix M ok so actually before I before
I do that um let me note that like if
you take one thing away from the talk
it's this definition and the fact that
generically this definition captures up
to some contention among the authors of
these papers the construction that's
used to prove SDPs we've sum of squares
lower bounds for CSP is the best known
such lower bounds it captures the
construction used to prove lower bounds
for planted cleek it captures the
best-known lower bounds for a number of
machine learning problems components
analysis style problems so somehow this
unifies many existing sum of squares sdp
lower bound constructions ok so let me
do some brief refresher on discrete
Fourier analysis so we can talk about
what it means to project this function
lambda to low degree polynomials and
then we'll wrap up the talk by getting
our hands a little bit dirty and getting
some very explicit expression for this
thing that you know if you want to try
it for yourself maybe it's a calculation
you can take home with you
ok so brief refresher on discrete
Fourier analysis
what we interested in real-valued
functions on the n-dimensional hypercube
where I'm going to write capital n so
not to be confused with the little end
that we were talking about over here and
I'm going to think of this hypercube as
being on plus minus 1 and it's a it's a
classic theorem that every such function
f can be expressed as a degree at most
capital two times capital and polynomial
have n polynomial degree capital n
polynomial to see how this expression
works the key ideas are that there
exists a simple inner product of
functions from the hypercube to R and
that with respect to this inner product
there's a simple orthonormal basis of
functions called the Fourier characters
so we'll just see those very quickly so
if f and g are two functions like this
the inner product of F and G is the
expectation over a random X from the
capital n-dimensional hypercube f of X
times G of X and there is some there's
an orthonormal basis
of functions
hi alpha where alphas are subsets of the
coordinates and will see an explicit
expression for what Chi Alpha czar whoa
kind of huapi writing these are just the
monomials exactly so they're just the
monomials of plus minus 1
so it's a classical that if I take high
alpha of X to be equal to just the
product over the coordinates and alpha
of X I then these are orthogonal
functions with respect to this inner
product and every function f is equal
has an expansion in terms of these
functions where f hat alpha is are real
numbers and these fourier coefficients f
hat alpha are given by the inner product
of F by alpha which is just equal the
expectation under a random point on the
hypercube plus 1 to the N f of X Phi
Alpha X ok
there's our refresher and the whole
reason to describe this is because
secretly random graphs which we were
talking about up until now random graphs
are just random samples from the little
n choose 2 dimensional hypercube right
so back to us in the Indian half G and
half the air - rainy distribution is the
uniform distribution on the capital n is
little n choose 2 dimensional hypercube
so now the coordinates of this hypercube
are pairs of indices up from 1 up to
little n right and the distribution GN
1/2 is just a random sample from this
hypercube
which things already it's not like
normalize it no I think it should be
normalized correctly so exactly so the
reason that doesn't satisfy
normalization is because there's this
there's this function sitting out here
that's yeah yeah so I think it was
defined but okay so just to be clear
about what normalization means let's
apparently have a parenthetical remark
here so normalization just stand right
in front of where I'm writing the
normalization is this constraints that
the upper left entry of the moment
matrix is equal to one right okay so why
wasn't I wasn't this satisfied well you
know the upper left entry of this matrix
well if I put empty set empty set here
then this is one but I multiplied by
this number which is potentially
enormous and the point is going to be
that the only the high degree part of
this function mu is able to be be spiky
like this and when I truncate it to low
degree it'll smooth out this spike and
the whole thing will turn it like what
will turn out to happen is that this
entry is very close to one good question
the point so it is the lowest possible
degree over here but I'm actually
interested in the low degree projection
of this so empty set denotes the degree
in terms of these sort of fantasy
variables X but I'm interested in the
degree of dependence on the graph which
is different so there's a trade out
there's a play up play off of two
notions of low degree okay
all right so I have ten minutes okay so
let me now write down the definition of
this guy in terms of this function
lambda that Aaron defined for us and
this discrete Fourier analysis setup and
then I'm gonna say something quite
briefly about how one analyzes these
these moment matrices so what are the
proof techniques in the literature and
that I think will be out of time so now
we can better get a bit more formal
about em so what does it mean to take
the low-degree projection of some
function so let's think about a
particular entry of this matrix s T so
you know lambda s T well by what we just
said so okay from from from this line
down Capital n is always equal to little
n choose 2 and capital lambda s T we
know just generically that it has a
Fourier expansion so it's equal to the
sum over alpha and these are subsets of
n choose 2 alpha hats s T sorry lambda
hat SC at alpha times the character for
alpha
and now MST og will just be equal to
this some where I some only over thus
the low degree monomial so here I'm
gonna say the degree of alpha is at most
capital D I'm gonna move in just a
second sorry lambda hat St Alpha Chi
Alpha G okay so this is an extremely
almost the most explicit expression that
we're going to get and now the last
thing I want to do is give you an idea
of what these things look like and why
like this is some funny looking function
but in some sense the function is
defined to be able to compute these
numbers so I'm going to show you that
there's a very easy computation of these
numbers and this is this is true in
planted leek but it's also true kind of
across all of the problems where you
where this technology gets used
I want to leave this up so let me get
rid of this
sorry tweeters
okay so I want to give you some idea of
why it's so why these these numbers
actually turn out to be very nice even
though we went through some relatively
convoluted path to get here so I'm just
going to look at the definition of this
thing lambda hat s T of alpha oh by
definition of a Fourier coefficient this
is the expectation under G sampled from
GN 1/2 that's our uniform distribution
on a hypercube of lambda s T of G times
the character alpha and now let's use
the definition of lambda this is the
expectation energy from G in 1/2 and 1/2
the relative density of G under the
planted distribution with respect to the
random distribution times the
expectation of so possible cliques in
the graph G times this think I alpha so
I just expanded this definition and now
I'm gonna use the definition of relative
density to swap out these underlying
distributions right so what does a
relative density do it just lets you say
that the this is by definition equal to
the expectation under graph sampled from
this planted cleek distribution so now
these graphs have honest-to-god cliques
in them and let's see I should say that
a pair X G was sampled from the planted
distribution so X is the indicator
vector of this large clique G is a graph
with an honest-to-god large clique in it
XS XT times Chi Alpha G ok so now from
here I'm not gonna carry out the rest of
this computation because I don't have
much time but the point is that the
definition of this function in terms of
a relative density allows for very
straightforward computation of these
Fourier coefficients right so at this
point it's like a very straightforward
combinatorial calculation you have an
explicit expression for this thing you
have an explicit expression for this
thing you know how to sample graphs from
this distribution erin told you how and
you can just evaluate this and it turns
out to cut to the chase that it's equal
to the size of the clique divided by n
to the number of vertices
these in the combined sets alpha s and T
you can do that calculation on your own
time in the remaining two minutes and
then I want to stop for questions I want
to say something about what kind of
techniques are used to analyze these
pseudo calibrated pseudo distributions
in the literature as far as I know there
are sort of two techniques that we know
to analyze these things and it would be
nice if there were a more unified
approach both of the techniques you know
okay so as we said the main difficulty
is showing some PS deenus some
positivity of these matrices alright
status knowing that they satisfy linear
constraints turns out to be not very
difficult the main difficulty is to show
difficulty is to show there with high
probability mg is a positive matrix okay
and we sort of know two techniques for
this um but both of the techniques maybe
some extra there are some more experts
on the CSP technique than I am in the
audience for sure but I think that both
techniques you can ultimately view as
producing some kind of chill Eskie
decomposition of this moment matrix
where that cheol-su decomposition itself
depends on the on the graph are on the
instance in the case of CS piece right
so what we would like but I think what
all these techniques eventually do is
they construct some other matrix
functions
let's I'm just gonna say L of G and Q of
G such that m approx factorizes in some
chill s key issue a as L of G times Q G
times L of G transpose and Q is roughly
a diagonal PSD matrix so somehow
analyzing you know the eigenvalues of m
directly is very difficult one once to
get get your hands on kind of a diagonal
matrix cuz then the eigenvalues are just
explicit numbers that you have your
hands on and you sort of you you do this
but you do this in a way that you keep
the dependence on the instance present
at all at all times so you construct
some kind of symbolic factorization and
all I can say is that the techniques for
doing this they seem right now to differ
fairly greatly between planted click
style problems by which I mean problems
where one is interested in kind of dense
dense inputs like G in half is a dense
graph and CSPs so you can there are many
authors of these papers are in the
audience and you can talk to them at the
break yeah I think that's I think that's
the last thing I want to say so we have
two minutes which will reserve for
questions yeah oh thanks
and thanks Aaron yeah Jess it's just a
Jian Chi off of Jia the same Senior
Technician ever that's right yes yes yes
the dependence on the so here I'm
telling you a number which is it's an
actual real number and the dependence on
the instance is that this eventual
moment matrix that you'll construct is
it's a low degree polynomial in the
graph this these numbers are the
coefficients of that low degree
polynomial and these characters carry
the dependence on the instance yeah yeah
so so somehow that's like the key thing
that we're hiding here choosing this big
DS okay let's say it let's say a few
general things so first of all if I
chose D to be you know capital n then I
would just get this function back and I
wouldn't have made any progress right so
I better not do that on the other hand
if I choose D to be zero then I get the
expectation under I of this function
which is nice and PSD but it doesn't
turn out to set like I've lost all the
dependence on the instance right so I
can't possibly satisfy all of the
constraints of the SDP so I need to do
something in between and it's really
non-trivial that choosing some D in
between gets you something positive
semi-definite this is why we go through
all of this trouble it turns out that
generally
I think you you should take let's see
capital D should be roughly little D
times log of n for dense problems and
capital D should be about some large
constant times little D for sparse
problems
this actually brings me to a point that
I wasn't able to address in the talk
which is that so okay you know up to
this log which is not that terribly
important the point is Big D is like a
little bit bigger than little D but not
that much it's not asymptotically very
much larger one thing I want to address
is that you can without going through
the pain of analyzing these moment
matrices you can make in like remarkably
accurate prediction for when they're
going to be positive semi-definite just
by choosing the appropriate D according
to some rule like this and then
inspecting how well behaved individual
entries of these matrices are so once an
individual entry has say a variance
which is vastly larger than a diagonal
entry of the matrix basically you're
just screwed right this matrix is not
going to be PSD once some off diagonal
entries variance is overwhelming the
behavior on the diagonal so that's an
easy computation to do you just you know
this explicit polynomial you can compute
its variance you can see what happens in
the diagonal it's easy to compare these
things and it turns out to be true for
every planted problem that I know that
as soon as the variance of these off
diagonal entries becomes smaller than
what mass you have on the diagonal then
the matrices become positive
semi-definite so that's there's some
very easy once you know this degree you
just write out the darn polynomial
compute some variances of entries on the
off diagonal and you get a prediction
that then it turns that seems to be
always right about what the eventual sum
of squares lower bound you're going to
be able to prove this which may just
like these thingies or these thingies
this M guy yeah great question okay so
two answers answer number one is that
let's let's pop out of this planted
cleek example so in the case of planted
cleek you have to be slightly clever a
small tweak is needed here exactly right
if it were the case that the constraints
of the SDP
did not depend on the instance and this
is true for constraint satisfaction
problems for example right there you
just want something to be boolean then
it'll actually satisfy it for free if
you have constraints whose dependence on
the instance is low degree so
this mean like the constraints the
constraints of the planet click STP they
depend only on size little D
neighborhoods of the graph right which
is some sort of low degree function of
the graph then you can make some kind of
similarly low degree modification to
this M which will which will basically
ensure that it satisfies those
constraints exactly also they Xuan CSP
is by the way because CSP is we want to
satisfy the crosses exactly which means
they are constraints are dependent
things ah sorry so if you write a couple
of versions of CSP s if you do see SPS
where you put the clauses all in the
objective function then this is not a
word you can also do a stronger version
of a CSP s some semi definite program
where you add them as kind of more
bigger families of constraints and then
you have this same issue that you need
to make some little tweaks to M some of
these tweaks turn out to occur like you
can think of the tweaks occurring is
very far out in this sum so for out you
only need to modify alphas that are very
close to this to this little to this Big
D and I didn't you know we saw this
example where the magnitude of these
coefficients decays exponentially and
what that means is that making small
modifications out at the at the end of
this capital D makes like the the norm
of the change that you make is really
tiny
you'd understand it won't that for
example what you say that means the
other SS large gaps at the moment site
because you get so bad solution right
yes yes right if you were a small gap
for enemies more gap you disability move
that says way certificates right yes we
think so so the moment site is better
for large gaps and I think that's true
you know if you just want to prove small
gaps I think it's I agree that it's you
want to study study the proofs the SOS
proof side when you eventually give
algorithm so not just proving small
integrality gaps but eventually you want
to extract integral solutions then then
the the things that we know how to do
tend to work simultaneously in the
primal and the dual so they often
construct some SOS proof and then use
that SOS proof to design a rounding
algorithm in the in the moment matrix
side does that make sense yeah but there
is like there are there are examples for
example there's this series of work on
unique games and maxcut worst-case
integrality gaps in which the whole the
whole arguments take place in the SOS
proof side and you're showing that for
particular interesting in unique games
instances or maxcut instances that there
exists a low degree SOS proofs that
certify optimal values for these
instances yes sir the small gaps
literature I most familiar with
wait thank you all sign-up sheet for
local second